this is Matt gray he gives high fives
and this is a cardboard cutout of Matt
gray assembled by a crack team of
professionals but which one can get more
high fives in ten minutes tonight on the
mean streets of York we find out this is
the Matt gray high-five face on well you
join us here on this cloudy December
afternoon in York cutouts in position
and that's ready so let's start the
clock
both of them have ten minutes to get as
many high fives as possible so start the
cut out there but Matt's straight off
with the left-handed double take spin an
excellent opening gambit for two points
a bit of interest from some local kids
there but no only one high-five given
there that's just one point big attempt
Matt's going for the pensioners she
spurned him but yes that's good the band
of struck up by the cutout and it looks
quiet no wait thank you madam glad you
enjoyed it
three minutes in and it looks like
that's having a bit of trouble following
people doesn't help that much I want
that's a raised child slow slap one
point for the cut out there he's asking
the questions but he's not getting the
answer he wants
that's not a high-five that's a punch in
the hand mister she's of some kind oh
that's a high ten that's the kind of
professionalism we've come to expect
from the content of this caliber shear
plus the cutout left mostly ignored with
the lull in the crowd I'm fairly certain
max pulling ahead one from the child and
one from the mother housewives favorite
Matt gray strikes again
big big crowds here today oh what's this
oh that's incredible
a double granny simultaneous sideswipe I
haven't seen one of those since Italy in
the semi-finals in 1983 and where did
she come from out of nowhere that's
where out of nowhere and back to the
streets and he's got a second one
unbelievable even if the kids in hats go
for the cutout surely it doesn't stand a
chance now Matt gray in full-on bounce
mode now surely nothing can stop this
contender he's absolutely in the zone
and the cutout is just left standing
still one two three four in a row this
is incredible she's not going to be
enough to save the cadets chances and
with the clock starting to run short oh
that's a full-on power blast that's got
to hurt but it just doesn't show and
even the crowds at the cutout seem to
sense the impending crushing defeat and
all I won it seems you can get the stuff
these days no contest here now Matt gray
is dozens of high-fives ahead of his
competitor the cutout just getting
scored locks from teenage girls I hate
with the under-18 crowd until the 30s as
I said before housewives favorite inking
cards just can't compete there one two
three
even the police it seems have no
interest in a free high five from the
cutout oh what's this it's a traffic
warden can he get the traffic water yes
yes unbelievable the first authority
figure of the night the points go to
Matt gray in the final ten seconds the
cutout I'm sure thinks it's all over oh
it is now I'm flying two handed Buster
jump with follow-through
never attempted professional competition
before but it worked the final scores
ladies and gentlemen the end of the
round the end of a contest it's a
staggering 112 to Matt gray and only 23
to his cardboard replica that has been
the Matt gray high-five face-off the
victor Matt gray
[Music]